السودان يسقط في وحل الاقتتال بين اقوى
الرجلين عسكريين في البلاد فانقطاع حبل
الود بين عبد الفتاح البرهان ومحمد حمدانو
اوقع السودان في المحظور اتهامات وتوعد
وتهديد بالقتل هكذا تحول الخطاب بين
الرجلين الذين نسفا في لحظات علاقه تحالف
وعمل مشترك دامت نحو 20 عاما الرجلان عمل
سويا لاول مره سنه 2003 حين اتحدا للتصدي
لجماعات المسلحه في اقليم دارفور الملقب
بحميتي انشا حينها مجموعه صغيره مسلحه
ووضع يده في يد البرهان الذي كان حينها
منسقا لعمليات الجيش في دارفور ومنذ ذلك
الحين والرجلان يصعدان المراتب بشكل
تدريجي عاد ليتصدر المشهد سنه 2019 حين
اتحدا من جديد وهذه المره ليس الا لاسقاط
عمر البشير الذي قاتلا تحت رايته سويا قبل
16 عاما
هدف مشترك جمعهما ليبرما تحالفا
استراتيجيا لكن انهاء مهام الحكومه
المدنيه وسيطره البرهان الى جانب حميتي
على الحكم خليفه سنه 2021 حمل معه اولى
شذرات الخلاف الحقيقيه فالبرهان اعاد بعد
عناصر نظام البشير الى السلطه وهو ما
اعترض عليه حميتي لكن نقطه التي افادت
الكاس تمخضت عن الاتفاق الاطاري الذي حمل
بين ثناياه مقترح اصلاح النظام العسكري
ودمج قوات الدعم السريع مقترح كان مجرد
قنبله موقوته انفجرت لتنهي تحالفا
استراتيجيا وتشعل عداوه قد تحرق نيرانها
البلاد وسام الذهبي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات